[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here who loves a
good pokeball it is currently my
favorite dinner if you have no idea what
a pokeball is you are missing out and
you need to start adding this dish into
your meals so be sure to watch this
video through okay so pokeball is a
traditional Hawaiian dish typically
served with raw fish slices rise lots of
vegetables and other toppings such as
avocado mango nuts and seeds and more so
it is nutritious and delicious the best
part about pokeball is that you can keep
changing the ingredients according to
your liking and also your mood so here
are five steps to make a really healthy
pokeball so the first step is to choose
your base it can either be brown rice
sushi rice quinoa couscous or even
noodles the second step is to pick your
protein it can either be salmon tuna
prawns or for vegans you can go for tofu
and the third step is to pack on the
vegetables and also fruits such as
lettuce cabbage cucumber cherry tomatoes
avocado mango and more so pack as many
varieties of vegetables as you want the
next step is to add the toppings such as
sesame seeds scallions onions and nuts
and seeds of your choice and the final
step is to drizzle the sauce to really
pack in the flavors so I'm going to
share with you three of my favorite
pokeball recipes salmon sashimi on wild
rice salty prawns on glass noodles and
of course we need a vegan option
marinated tofu on quinoa so let's start
by making the sauce which will be used
for all three recipes so in a bowl mix
in 1 tablespoon of soy sauce 1/2 a
teaspoon of rice wine vinegar and about
half a tablespoon of fresh lemon juice
and set aside let's start with the
salmon sashimi on wild rice what you'll
need are 1 cup of cooked rice I used
wild rice about 1/3 cup of raw salmon
cut into cubes quarter of an avocado cut
into cubes quarter cup of steamed
edamame
quarter cup of mango cut into cubes we
want to start by marinating the salmon
so in a small bowl mix in the soy sauce
sesame oil and sesame seeds then pour
the sauce on to the salmon coat and let
it sit for about 15 minutes
then all you have to do is assemble the
dish in a bowl so always start with a
base which is the rice and arrange the
rest of the ingredients finally drizzle
with a little bit of sauce and serve
just look at this dish guys it is
colorful it's packed with all the good
stuff and is so flavoursome this One
Bowl has about 465 calories I would be
happy to eat this every single day so
the next recipe is the sauteed prawns on
glass noodles what you'll need are 80
grams of glass noodles 1/3 cup of prawns
peeled cut a cup of cabbage shredded
quarter cup of cherry tomatoes 1/2 2
tablespoons of cucumber sliced 1
tablespoon of toasted seaweed shredded
and half a tablespoon of sesame oil
let's start by prepping the noodles in a
large bowl place the noodles and pour
enough boiling water over the noodles
then just cover with a plate and let it
soak for about 10 to 15 minutes until
the noodles are soft and just drain the
water off in a small bowl makes a
dessert sauce rice vinegar garlic and
sesame seeds and pour the mixture over
the prawns and allow the prawns to
marinate for about 5 minutes next heat
the sesame oil over medium-high heat
then add the marinated prawns and cook
very quickly just for about 4 to 5
minutes until the prawns are pink don't
overcook them it's time to assemble the
dish again always start with the base
which is the glass noodles and arrange
the rest of the ingredients your prawns
your vegetables and your toppings
finally drizzle with a little bit of
sauce and serve so this one Bowl has
about 443 calories
for the vegetarians and vegans out there
this final recipe is for you so for the
marinated tofu on quinoa what you'll
need are 1 cup of quinoa cooked about
1/3 block of firm tofu drained and cut
into cubes quarter of an avocado cut
into cubes cut a cup of carrot shredded
2 tablespoons of corn and about 2
tablespoons of cucumber sliced so again
let's start by marinating the tofu in a
small bowl combine the soy sauce sesame
oil garlic sesame seeds and red pepper
flakes coat the tofu and leave it to
marinate for about five to 10 minutes
and it's my favorite part again time to
put this dish together so we've got the
quinoa tofu and all the vegetables hold
the sauce mixture and sprinkle with more
sesame seeds and serve this one ball has
about 435 calories all these recipes
will keep you full for a long period of
time and it will give you the energy to
keep going so the great thing is you can
keep experimenting with different
ingredients different base and different
protein so you won't feel bored eating
the same thing over and over again so I
don't want to hear that healthy food is
boring alright so each Bowl is packed
with complex carbs clean protein healthy
fat and lots of vegetables how do you
like your pokeball let me know in the
comments below be sure to try this
recipe out because I trust you will be
hooked ok do take pictures of your
creation and share them with me on
Facebook and Instagram tag me at
Jonassen official and hashtag chase of
recipes because I want to see all your
healthy pokeballs
do also like this video share this video
and subscribe to my youtube channel for
a lot more healthy recipes workout
videos and also fitness tips guys do you
also turn on your notification button so
that you will get notified every time I
upload a new video all the best